in the continued authoritarian nepeta
stays that a word crony istic slide
Donald Trump in the wake of the
announcement of UN Ambassador Nikki
Haley's resignation for unknown in
questionable reasons possibly involving
a federal ethics probe that's been
requested Donald Trump has said that
there could be no one more competent in
the world to replace UN Ambassador nikki
Haley than his own daughter Ivanka Trump
now you probably are hearing me say this
and you're thinking David you must have
misunderstood it must be an onion
article or a really good impression on
SNL it's it can't really be that Trump
said something like this oh no it's on
video that's exactly what Donald Trump
said take a look at this I've heard a
lot of them I've heard Ivanka I've heard
how good would Ivanka be the people that
know there's nothing to do with nepotism
but I want to tell you the people that
know know that Ivanka would be dynamite
but you know I'd then be accused of
nepotism if you can believe it right you
believe
[Music]
I think Ivanka would be incredible that
you know it I figure because you'd be
accused of nepotism even though I'm not
sure there's anybody more confident in
the world but that's okay but but we are
looking at numerous people I like that
you know I even cut my own daughter
would be the best person to actually be
ambassador to the UN but if you can
believe this crazy thing I'd be accused
of nepotism yeah I can believe it that's
the definition of nepotism well I'm
gonna defend the president here for a
second because in Trump circles yeah
perhaps Ivanka is the most competent one
like people like scare Moochie working
for him and Kellyanne Conway and Ryan
Spicer Ivanka is better than all of them
but he said not the most qualified in DC
or in my administration he said the most
competent in the world I love how he
says nepotism but forgetting about
nepotism for a second Ivanka would be
the best but people would say nepotism
so that's the problem the problem is not
that he immediately starts thinking
about could I put a member of my family
in this position maybe he goes too it
would be something that the left would
slam me for unfairly of course would
Ivanka Trump be considered as ambassador
to the UN as a possibility by any other
President or even by any other person
outside of trumps family were Trump not
president the answer's no she would only
even enter someone's mind as a possible
ambassador to the UN on the basis of
being Trump's kid which means of course
that it is nepotism and I'm going to
tell you right now I know people in the
audience may not like this if Donald
Trump wants Ivanka as ambassador to the
UN Trump probably gets Ivanka as
ambassador to the UN right the
debasement of our politics and of all
that is good and proper means Trump
probably wouldn't be stopped I mean who
would do it are Republicans in the House
or Senate gonna punish Trump for making
Ivanka ambassador to the UN no if Trump
wants her in there like I'm not saying
he actually wants her in there but if he
did Fox and Friends would start talking
about why not Ivanka she knows everybody
she's well-liked she's
did I mean great great person great body
trump has told us about her great body
many times it was weird when he said it
but he did I don't think they stopped it
if Trump really wants I mean there are
anti-nepotism laws on the books
yeah but they could skirt around them
that's how they got Ivanka into the
White House as an adviser on pages you
just don't pay her yeah and I think
that's a sacrifice she would be willing
to make this would be different this
seems as though it would go against five
US codes subsection 31 10 about the
employment of relatives but who cares
because it hasn't mattered so far and
the law says that during a national
security crisis the president all of a
sudden can appoint a relative they'll
say there are Mexicans pouring in it is
a national security crisis therefore
Ivanka as ambassador to the UN or the
Russia probe is a national security
crisis we've got to put Ivanka Trump in
as ambassador to the UN and Ivanka Trump
she knows China
she knows Japan absolutely she knows
India she's the perfect fit I would say
don't stop here I would say go further
Donald Trump jr. for Secretary of State
get the North Korea thing straightened
out once and for all Pompey owes failing
put in Don Junior Baron Trump can be a
head of cyber security of course he and
Tiffany Trump may be like deputy press
secretary but not really doesn't like
their yeah Trump really doesn't like
Tiffany does he know this is the third
ring of the circus okay it's all coming
full circle we've got the debasement of
our politics and culture too grotesque
glows we've got as I mentioned twice now
in the last 48 hours the radicalization
of institutions of government including
the Supreme Court including the
Environmental Protection Agency our
voting systems the courts media and then
the fully authoritarian I would call it
a day Newmont of officially pushing his
family into positions of power official
positions not just I have an office near
daddies and I hang out but nobody pays
me we're in real trouble
you had better vote next month seriously
let me know what your thoughts are I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we'll
be back after this what would it look
like if we all listened more listening
to audiobooks can
motivate us can inspire us it can bring
us closer together and there's no better
place to listen than audible because now
audible members get even more there's
exclusive audio fitness programs
audiobooks audible originals and more
they've got the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet and now with
audible originals the selection has even
more custom content made just for
members every month audible members get
one credit good for any audiobook you
choose to select that they can't get
anywhere else they also get access to
audio fitness and health workouts
created exclusively for audible plus
your ebooks are yours to keep with
audible you can go back and re-listen
anytime even if you cancel your
membership don't like your audiobook
exchange it no questions asked I
recently listened to homo Deus by you've
all know a Harare excellent excellent
book I encourage you to start a 30-day
trial and your first audiobook will be
free go to audible.com slash Pakman or
text Pakman PA que ma n to 500 500 on
your phone that's AUD
ible dot-com slash Pakman or text Pakman
to 500 500 you can do it with audiobooks